sur ce site
nous sommes environ 3000 collaborateurs
plutôt versées dans les métiers de light
y ait des moyens de paiement et des
opérations bancaires
pourquoi les 48 heures techno parce que
ici nous souhaitons faire en sorte que
les collecteurs souhaite exposer aux
nouvelles technologies au numérique et
plus globalement la digitalisation de
notre économie et de notre société
le robot doté les présents a tenté par
la poste et atos techno dans nos métiers
bancaires vous êtes tous clients d'une
banque tous rendez compte de plus en
plus ce sont
la banque par internet vous n'avez plus
dans votre agence et donc il faut que
nos colocataires pu suivre le mouvement
un mouvement qui accélère aujourd'hui
par rapport aux années passées
donc cet événement c'est la rencontre de
environ huit fournisseurs stratégiques
partenaires ses actes et j'aime groupes
qui vont de microsoft accenture ibm
oracle mais également des start up
puisque le monde aujourd'hui c'est des
start up
les start-ups et toi c'est la rapidité
c'est le service scellait la simplicité
donc on fait cet événement pour ça en
plus des start up qui sont forcément
aussi implanté sur le territoire
parce que nous souhaitons développer
l'économie territoriale
nous avons une chance extraordinaire
d'avoir à côté de nous des fleurons de
l'industrie française comme airbus
safran thales est également un élément
qui rond dans notre dynamique on a créé
notre programme de transformation c'est
le cluster paris saclay peu
d'entreprises ont cette chance d'avoir à
côté de chez eux
on va dire demain le huitième pôle
scientifique mondiale et 25% de la
recherche de notre objectif en faisant
ça c'est de montrer qu'une entreprise
comme une banque où on pense que la
bombe ce n'est que des conseillers
clients non la banque c'est le de plus
en plus le digital de plus en plus le
numéro est donc en faisant cet événement
s'est aussi montrée sur le territoire et
notamment aux jeunes que les métiers de
la bourse ont des métiers d'avenir